can you give us the hint of anything any
I don't want to you know get you in
trouble with the studio or Marvel but I
mean maybe could you even just a little
title do we know the title could you
[Applause]
alright I think I could probably tell
you that I think it's out there already
the the title of the next Avengers movie
is
[Music]
that's out there I can't believe you
just told us that's the biggest that's
out there I don't want to get in trouble
I swear it up
no all right it's okay yeah are you sure
yeah I'm it that's I I thought it was a
spoiler I mean we all reacted to it
that's I mean could he could he give us
a another spoiler I think we giving away
too much so in the final battle Bruce
banners in
all right yeah and and he wakes up and
he's like
turns into the hockey's boss side of
this tank
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie so mark
ruffalo tried to spoil a whole bunch of
stuff about Avengers 4 he said that the
title is out there so I do think that he
was actually mouthing something and they
believed it and they just nd8
everybody in the crowd just to be clear
though that's not me bleeping that video
that's directly taken from Jimmy
Fallon's broadcast so whatever they were
doing the people did that while Mark
Ruffalo was speaking there's a new
spider-man ps4 game giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video you may
have heard the rumor about Avengers
annihilation lately that's like the
latest supposed inside rumor Mark
Ruffalo saying it's out there here's the
other thing too they bleeped him the
whole time he was trying to give away
his spoilers but they put a black bar in
front of his mouth when he was speaking
about the title then when he did his
second subsequent spoiler filled rant
they didn't cover his mouth at all they
just bleeped him again just more
evidence that the title like he said was
out there he wasn't lying when he said
it's out there so it's not really a
spoiler because people already know it
but since it's not Marvel officially
revealing it on all of their social
media accounts you just have to take it
with a grain of salt and if you haven't
read the annihilation storyline that's
all about
Annihilus in the annihilation wave
trying to destroy all life in the
universe in Thanos sort of playing both
sides against each other and him getting
killed himself so it's not like fan OHS
verse the Avengers is a much much bigger
story and involves a whole bunch of
x-men based characters like Galactus
that Marvel doesn't have access to quite
yet like they just finish wrapping most
people on it
they still haven't finished the deal
with Fox so if annihilation really is
the title then they're probably just
borrowing the themes of that story in
that because of something that Thanos
does say erasing half of all life it
leaves the universe vulnerable to
another attack that's going to wipe out
all life during the comic book storyline
Annihilus enters our universe the 6-1-6
marvel universe through this bleed
between universes they call the crunch
in the negative zone Drax winds up
killing Thanos there's a whole bunch of
double-crosses Galactus reveals that
because of what's happening with the
annihilation wave in Santos's actions a
couple of ancient gods that he and
prisoned if the dawn of the universe
have been freed and are now threatening
everyone so it's just absolute chaos in
what they might do because they said
that Avengers 4 is supposed to have a
totally different plot from infinity war
it's not even part to that even though
Thanos will return it's not just gonna
be the Avengers reversing everything
that he did it applies the plot is gonna
be much more complex than that so you
could wind up with a scenario where the
Avengers do have to get Thanos his help
with something
the only storyline I could see that
would involve fan OHS working with the
Avengers on some level if there's some
greater threat that threatens all life
not just half of all life would be
something from like Marvel's the end
storyline which is non-canonical but it
involves this really crazy twist with
Thanos absorbing the universe and then
killing himself sacrificing himself so
that everyone can live and they reboot
everything but that comic book storyline
isn't canon to the main comics so there
just could be a situation where we wind
up getting rid of Thanos through some
slightly different means like right now
it's all about nebula getting revenge on
Thanos for everything that he did to her
as well as what he did to Kimora but
there really isn't a whole lot of
footage from behind the scenes that
corroborates anything that happens
during the annihilation storyline like
we're still thinking about this on a
pretty simple level with them just
trying to get everybody that was turned
to ash back you probably heard the
rumors about Ronan Hawkeye in the
scrolls scrolls were involved during the
night elation storyline but mostly the
super scroll the Kree the Nova Corps it
was a very space-based storyline so
obviously they were used quite a bit fun
fact
annihilation conquest was a spinoff of
that storyline that served as the origin
for the new guardians of the galaxy team
the served as the basis for the movie
team that we've been watching in the MCU
this whole time
so I'm still trying to take this with a
grain of salt I wouldn't call this
absolutely confirmed but it definitely
suggests that that's probably the title
because I still think that he was
speaking truthfully when he said that
the title is out there meaning that
people have figured it out and have been
talking about it it would still fit with
what the Russos were teasing the other
day because of those two ladders and the
two A's that they formed like a a it's
supposed to be a single subtitle so it's
not going to be multiple words and
they've already confirmed that it's not
Avengers end game Avengers forever
Avengers eternity legacy Avengers
Assemble or Avengers
so if it's still two titles in its two
A's they're just only a couple of
possibilities for what it could be let
me know in the comments though do you
think that he was actually mouthing the
real title and Marvel is just going to
reveal it at a later date or Marvel but
I mean maybe could you even just a
little do we know the title of the next
movie because Kevin Feige did say that
we would learn the title after we got
Captain Marvel then they would
officially start promoting Avengers for
like they would for a normal film by the
end of the year so I'm not really
expecting any big footage or anything
like that to like November or December
but there is a certain cycle for these
things so like the title is something
that will probably be learning really
really soon from Marvel's official
channels not just the Mark Ruffalo Tom
Hollands spoiler Bros Channel there'll
be more venom stuff happening tomorrow
uh name the giveaway winner when I post
that there's a couple videos that I'm
behind on click here for that new
Avengers for Captain America teaser and
click here for my non-spoilery venom
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]